hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein video aus der
kategorie stay on tour
ich zeige euch heute mal was sich
außerhalb meiner rezept wie das auch
noch schönes machen darf und zwar geht
es im heutigen video um eine gute sache
um eine charity aktion wobei er sogar
eine ganz große rolle mitspielt und es
vielleicht gar nicht wusste ich erkläre
euch das mal kurz also erkennt ja meine
küchenmaschine die kitchenaid beate sind
die gibt es ja in verschiedenen farben
und bisher war es immer so dass die
kitchenaid in rosa immer einen kleinen
aufpreis hatte und zwar wurde immer ein
teil des betrages an einen brustkrebs
verein gespendet er in den letzten
jahren war es immer so dass etwa pro
jahr 80 bis 90 tausend euro spenden
summe zusammengekommen sind
was wirklich schon enorm viel ist und
auch diesen verein wirklich ganz viel
bringt und den verein auch sehr viel
weiter bringt weil er einfach ganz tolle
aktion und durchführen kann
die ich euch später dann noch zeigen
werde aber seit diesem jahr ist es so
dass es nicht mehr die kitchenaid in
rosa sondern die kitchenaid himbeereis
ist also die kinder die ich eben auch zu
hause habe dieses schöne funkelnde
pinkfarbene kitchenaid und jetzt haben
wir dieses jahr eine rekord summe
erreicht und das macht mich persönlich
natürlich auch sehr stolz und deswegen
durfte ich oder darf ich mit kitchenette
zusammen und zwar mit dem herrn teils in
frankfurt das spendengeld überreichen
und zwar an den verein aktion pink und
es ist ein vereint da setzt sich eben
für brustkrebs erkrankte ein arbeiter
hat jetzt nicht nur therapie sondern es
geht eben auch um prävention also dass
die brust einfach auch gesund bleibt und
gar nicht erst erkrankt so weit es eben
geht bei der aktion pink gibt es drei
vorstände und die haben heute ein
galadinner gemacht und zwar für die
ganzen ehrenamtlichen helfer die sich
immer so toll einsetzen und auch
mithelfen und bei dieser aktion pink ist
es so jedes jahr sind verschiedene
rennen da das heißt in berlin
in frankfurt in hamburg und in ganz
vielen anderen städten und da freuen
sich auch die brustkrebs erkrankten
immer sehr weise einfach dann eine
motivation haben und ansporn haben sich
einfach wieder zu bewegen ein bisschen
sport zu machen und die trainieren dann
auch wirklich monatelang um bei diesem
race also bei diesen rennen mitzumachen
das rennen nennen sie auch immer race
oft das survivor und das finde ich
wirklich ganz toll
und da sind wir jetzt heute abend bei
einem gala-dinner denn der vorstand
möchte einfach den ehrenamtlichen
mitgliedern sag ich jetzt mal so einen
dank zurückgeben und steht dann in der
küche und kocht eine mehr gänge menü für
die ganzen ehrenamtlichen und das sind
wir heute mit dabei und werden am ende
dieser skala den us dann die spenden
summe übergeben
und wie der ganze abend abgelaufen ist
das seht ihr jetzt gleich jetzt haben
wir nämlich nach frankfurt wo die liebe
corinna schaue auf mich wartet
er kocht jetzt gerade noch fleißig was
gibt's dann später leckere ein kleines
fünf-gänge-menü soll schon mal sagen was
also wir beginnen mit einer kleinen
vegetarischen brühl mit einer suppe dann
gibt es einen mit kräuter salat mit
pinienkernen abgelöst wird das nun eine
variation garnelen lachs soßen mit
kleinen grünen spargel dann gibt es ein
zitronensorbet und der
vorstandsvorsitzende macht da hinten
schon das ruder für das sie
zitronensorbet danach gibt es ein
gulasch mit kartoffeln com ketten und
danach dann macht unsere bücher debug
aktionen die desserts gleich hilfst du
ja auch mit dazu erkläre ich habe meine
scherze ein gefragt wurde was auf mich
zukommt das klingt schon sehr lecker ich
bin gern wissen was macht dann überhaupt
euer verein
wir heißen aktion pink wir sind seit
1999 ein deutscher eingetragener verein
und wir kümmern uns um das thema heilung
von brustkrebs das war früher so unser
hauptthema mittlerweile haben wir es
etwas fokussiert auf den erhalt der
brustgesundheit also wir möchten auch
vorsorge betreiben damit die brust
einfach gesund bleibt ihm gar nicht erst
erkannt wenn das in unserer macht steht
tun alles dafür ansonsten wenn die
frauen natürlich betroffen sind von
brustkrebs dass wir hier ansprechpartner
sind und was war die idee dahinter
hinter dem verein
es gibt ja in deutschland ganz viele
organisationen die als wunderbare arbeit
machen aber es ist sehr schwierig die
frauen die natürlich diese diagnose
erhalten
auch zugreifen emotional zu packen damit
sie sich nicht nur in der therapie
gefangen fühlen also nicht nur eine
chemotherapie die op
an dem strahlung denken und alles was
damit zusammenhängt sondern einfach
versuchen die auch ein bisschen
wegzunehmen von den fokus nur auf die
erkrankung und mit blick auf die
genesung
das haben wir natürlich wunderbar
geschafft haben das jetzt schon 17 mal
wunderbar erfolgreich hinbekommen race
for survival früher hieß es race for the
cure jetzt seit ersten vierten race pro
survival und wir haben dort eine
einzigartige stimmung also als beruf ja
ich weiß
man darf gar nicht mehr zeigen dass man
für sich selbst treffen seine sache so
begeistert ist aber das ist wirklich
eine eine großartige geschichte machen
weil wir haben dort frauen betroffene
bei uns heißen die survivor die kommen
die laufen dort mit und die haben 2500
enkel bekommen dafür dass wir die frauen
schon während der therapie und bewegung
bringen das heißt also in die laufschuhe
jeden tag zwei meter um den
klinikbereich es geht nicht um
schnelligkeit nicht um gewinnen so
einfach dabei zu sagen wenn die wissen
in drei vier monaten ist der race dann
möchte ich dabei sein in frankfurt in
köln in hamburg in leipzig dann kommen
die dazu und dann haben wir ein ziel und
mein fokus darauf und den kies einfach
viel besser
es ist ja nicht so dass die jetzt
komplett sind aber sie haben einen ganz
anderen motivation an die an dieser
krankheit anzugehen und dafür sind wir
mit dem herz angel belohnt worden auf
dem josef stolz sind
was tut der verein um die bevölkerung
auf zu sensibilisieren also gerade mit
dem thema brustkrebs also allerdings
schon immer noch ein bisschen tabuthema
das redeten hier herrn jemand krüger
natürlich weil jeder denkt an dieses
damoklesschwert
also wieso lässt die frauen
jeder hat angst diese diagnose zu
erhalten das ist ganz klar
aber ich sage immer bekannt machen muss
man es eigentlich nicht mehr also wir
haben jetzt schon wirklich so viele
jahre daran gesetzt und haben das
wirklich pinkfarben vorangebracht nicht
nur wie auch andere vereine und
vereinigungen die pinkfarbenen schweife
kennt auch jeder kennt natürlich auch
sagen und das ist wirklich die jüngsten
schülerinnen kennen sich daraus aber wir
gehen zum beispiel letztes jahr sind wir
in 60 hamburger schulen gegangen
schülerinnen auf dem sechzehnten
lebensjahr informiert über das thema
brustkrebs
ich gehe in die unternehmen also ich war
so sagen darf aber ich war vor 14 tagen
bei münchen
das war das mal so emotional die haben
so von wunderbare mitarbeiter gehabt
also ich hab dann vortrag gehalten
sensibilisieren nicht nur das thema
brustkrebs sondern auch ein bisschen
achtsamer mit sich selbst umzugehen das
muss man sich manchmal einfach so ein
bisschen wieder vor augen führen in dem
heutigen stress mir geht es nicht an
dass man vergisst die voruntersuchungen
einfach so ein bisschen inne zu halten
und das ist ganz wichtig zu stoppen und
zu sagen wie sehr ich den aus ich habe
also ich habe zum beispiel frauen die
wahren
die haben so große tumore sind so spät
entdeckt worden
die eine sagt das ist ja fast so einen
tennisball gewesen und wie konnte ich
denn das übersehen
das sind ja keine dumme frauen oder eine
unachtsam fragen ja einfach ein bisschen
ihren sieger mit sich selbst und wie
gehen nicht nur mit den anderen sollen
sie jetzt auch und das möchten wir
anfragen bringen und wir gehen halt in
den schulen halten vorträge oder bei den
unternehmen das ist natürlich ganz toll
weil eine große reichweite auch und
unsere vorträge kommen auch sehr gut an
was muss ich sagen also bayerisch auch
mit darauf schieben und das macht mir es
gibt natürlich auch nie sehr viel denken
viele dankbar
ja das ist wirklich nicht weil wir das
thema versuchen es ist ein schweres
thema aber wir versuchen das thema
einfach ein bisschen leichter zu machen
weil die diagnose stellen was tut ihr
denn bisher erreicht und wir werden denn
die spenden dann eingesetzt
wir haben zum beispiel im moment das ist
immer noch in der bearbeitung ist
manchmal schon seit 2015 unser projekt
home doctors da geht es darum dass wir
die männer der betroffenen frauen
sensibilisieren wollen was die frauen
brauchen also viele rufen an sagen ja
soll ich fenster putzen soll ich
einkaufen gehen sind so wunderbar die
wollen dass alles machen aber die sind
nach sechs wochen jan ist ein umfrage
gestartet
das ist auch finanziert worden über
spendengelder umfrage vorliegen dass die
männer nach sechs wochen in der gleichen
stressigen situation sind im gleichen
stress status haben wir selbst hinterher
gewinnt und dann machen braucht man sich
nicht wundern dass manche männer ihre
frauen verlassen das machen die nicht
was ihre frau nicht mehr lieb haben sie
kommen nicht klar und völlig überfordert
sind und wir versuchen die männer dann
zu schulen und fit zu machen denen zu
zeigen was ihre frauen in der
krisensituation braucht weil das ist
eigentlich für mich persönlich das
größte anliegen wir möchten dass die
frauen während der krise einen partner
der seite haben der sie beschützt oder
see sorgt unterstützt dass sie wirklich
sich auf die genesung und dass da haben
ich glaube das auch so der wichtigste
punkt war scheint ja man hier auch der
partner wir eben schon angesprochen
natürlich bin ich auch auf den verein
aufmerksam geworden ganz klar inwieweit
unterstützt kitchenaid in euren verein
hier also großartig also ich habe ja
schon gesagt wir haben insgesamt schon
300.000 euro in den letzten jahren und
es war schon zwei mal so dass wir
wirklich knappe kasse hatten wir sehr
dankbar dass das geld anlegen und es ist
nicht nur die spende also was ich tue
mir da immer schwer weil ich bin
überhaupt kein material ist aber wir
brauchen ja
was machen da werden wir noch mal eine
rekord firma ja
300.000 euro also ich weiß gar nicht wie
ich mich bei den management schnitt
bedanken kann
wir sagen immer wir sind drei vorstände
und wir fühlen uns immer sehr stark
verbunden mit kitchenette wir sagen
immer wir fühlen uns so stark wie die
motoren der fitschen sehr stark sehr
stark belastbar
darauf sind wir auch sehr stolz und
deswegen es ist auch ein wunderbarer
partner wir werden ja nicht nur die
frauen über die vorsorge informieren was
natürlich ganz wichtig ist machen wir
machen ja ganz viele vereine auf aber
wir möchten natürlich in erster linie
unsere races voran bringen also weiter
races machen dass es keine
benefizveranstaltung sondern das sind
läufe für diese weise die betroffenen
die dadurch unglaublich motiviert werden
dabei sein zu können das hat mich
unglaublich genießens effekt auch und
immer wenn ihr kind steht natürlich als
haupt tombola preis dabei ist dann sind
die total begeistert ich sage immer also
so geschnitten hat jeder haben dann
vielleicht auch eine ganz wichtige frage
wie viele frauen sind denn überhaupt in
deutschland sind das jedes jahr über
70.000 neue krank für frauen und 700
männer und das überhaupt männer
erkranken das musste ich eigentlich
bevor das sich hierbei aktion vorstand
wurden wusste ich dass das nicht und das
schlimme ist auch die sind sehr hart
betroffen es gibt keine spezielle
therapien für die männer
sie werden also praktisch noch wie die
frauen behandelt mit chemo mit hormon
therapien sind wir natürlich nicht sehr
glücklich aber die forscher sind dran
und sie bemühen sich natürlich die
mediziner dass sie da individuell was
für die auch erschaffen können aber es
dauert noch ein bisschen also insoweit
gibt es denn auch bestimmte
risikofaktoren also kann man sagen das
begünstigt brustkrebs oder also
risikofaktoren sind erstmal genetisch
ich halte aber nur zwei prozent
die erkranken aufgrund der genetischen
oder genetische belastung das ist
verschwindend gering eigentlich und ganz
klar ist es natürlich vielleicht auch
umwelt belasten
es ist natürlich schon immer steigen
aber in erster linie nicht rauchen
ich habe julian sehr stark geraucht ich
rauche seit fast 30 jahren nicht mehr
also nicht rauchen wenig alkohol wenn
dann genießen in alkohol und versuche
natürlich genug sein zu ernähren aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen den meisten
mit denen ich spreche ändern sich ganz
top und was so ein bisschen mein
steckenpferd ist eine verbesserung der
psychosozialen beziehung
das ist das thema versuchen ein gesundes
leben vielleicht kein streit mit dem
nachbarn vielleicht mit dem man eine
bessere beziehung der schwiegermutter
oder so einfach mal gucken
es liegt nicht immer nur im
arbeitsalltag vielleicht sind es nicht
die kollegen sondern was eine separate
private umfeld aber das ist ganz wichtig
also die frauen sollten achtsam mit sich
selbst umgehen und vielleicht gut was
will man natürlich darf ich noch sagen
natürlich die selbstkontrolle auch also
wir frauen haben alle vier wochen die
chance und selbst abzutasten zu
kontrollieren
sehe ich noch so aus ist das fühlt sich
das noch so an wie vor vier wochen
40 prozent der frauen entdecken ihren
tumor selbst das muss man sich immer
wieder vor augen 40 prozent decken den
tumor selbst weist nicht nur über die
mammografie oder lesungen sondern selbst
heißt was wäre mit den frauen passiert
wenn die nicht achtsam mit sich
umgegangen wenn dies nicht entdeckt
hätte vielleicht ein jahr später zur
mammografie gegangen oder zur
untersuchung
dann wäre das date fortgeschritten und
wir sagen immer früherkennung rettet
leben
wie kann man denn euren verein
unterstützen also jetzt mal abgesehen
nicht nur von spendengeldern klar ein
verein lebt von spendengeldern braucht
er natürlich auch was kann man sonst
noch tun
also wir kochen hier heute abend für
unsere volontiert das herz wir bräuchten
natürlich ganz dringend in hamburg in
berlin den leipzig in dresden in
frankfurt in köln
ehrenamtliche wir haben ganz viele
helfer unter den betroffenen aber
natürlich wenn die frauen selbst
betroffen sind gibt es doch die diebe
dann aus wann kommen sie wieder wir sind
natürlich mehr hätte wenn sie dabei sind
aber wir brauchen wirklich mehr helfer
in den einzelnen städten wir suchen neue
race komitees die uns helfen die rays
aufzubauen weil das ist wirklich etwas
da sind wir deutschlandweit die einzigen
die das zu können
das würde betroffenen schulen der taten
das wir sehr stolz und das ist unser
steckenpferd das ist das was wir
wirklich können und dass wir natürlich
voran
da brauchen wir ganz viel ehrenamtliche
aber ich kann eins versprechen es macht
unglaublich spaß ich sage immer wer noch
keinen race gemacht hat in seinem leben
hat es auf jeden fall auch mal teil
vielleicht findet sich jetzt das nächste
mal alles klar
da liegt sicherlich noch was für
aktionen sind dann auch noch in zukunft
geplant also werdet ihr dieses weiterhin
fortführen na klar da möchten wir also
in erster linie so ein raise kostet ich
sag's mal 80.000 euro ob leute kommen
hilft das vergessen viele leute die
denken nur acht machen muss benefizlauf
also erst mal sind die kosten sehr hoch
machen zu organisieren und wenn wir
natürlich in der neuen stadt etwas
aufbauen wie jetzt in berlin nächstes
jahr muss man natürlich da auch sehr
viel investieren
aber wir wollen natürlich um so bringt
ihnen vor taschen wieder aufleben lassen
wir auch die einzigen deutschland die
das ist mein leben
das ist eine pinkfarbene tasche diesmal
bestimmt mit einem plus von zum beispiel
adecco mascara von einer anderen marke
und viel informationsmaterial aber das
sage ich immer wir sind also sehr darauf
bedacht dass wir unabhängig arbeiten
also wir arbeiten nicht mit pharmafirmen
werden möchten also
informationsmaterialien gestreut
wir sind also durchweg
und wir möchten dass die frauen alle
umfassend informiert werden und wir
haben da so ein kleines herzkissen das
war so schön das muss ich noch erzählen
bei kitchen geld die haben immer einen
wunderbaren stand bei der ambiente in
frankfurt und als ich letztes jahr zu
ambiente kam um den stand zu besuchen wo
die von hinten angriff und eine
verkaufsleiterin hat gesagt darf ich sie
umarmt
vielleicht nicht sie persönlich aber ihr
verein hat mir ein herzkissen geschäft
und sie sagt sie kam von der op raus und
sie hatte niemanden da kann man im
fernen verwandten ich gibt es leute
einfach wirklich wenig verwandte
unsicheren haben sagt den lack dann
herzkissen von uns das machen unsere
frauen ehrenamtlich die nehmen die
herzkissen mal die sehr hübsch und dann
liegt dann so ein herzkissen auf
im krankenbett und glaube ich komme ganz
gut an und was ich ihnen auch sagen dass
sie nicht jetzt nur
etliche größe sondern im herzen
therapeuten com
ich musste erst lernen herzkissen wird
nach der op unter die achsel gesteckt
ist das wenig angenehmer für die frauen
ersten tagen nach der op also es hat
seinen ganz speziellen natürlich auch
eine wir haben ganz viel vor wir werden
das dann auch veröffentlichen was wir
damit machen weil wir müssen erst mal
verdauen
er weist noch eine persönliche frage zum
abschluss was war das schönste erlebnis
für dich bisher im verein
das schönste erlebnis gibt es schon ganz
viele gerne geschichten also mein erster
race in frankfurt und da sind ja dann
bis zu 402 war die kommunale hält auch
mit den pink arman t shirts stehen am
schluss auf der bühne und dann lassen
wir unser lied laufen die singen dann
mit alban verleiht sowieso sehr
emotionales lied und dann sah ich ein
paar frauen wo ich dachte meine güte
diese mitgenommen aus also man sah die
hat mit der aps befestigt hinter sich
gebracht und ein jahr später habe ich
die frauen gesehen rosigen wangen
richtig gut erholt sie standen da wieder
ihr t shirt an weil das bald die auch
die wollen das ja noch zeigen
und die seien so klasse aus und da muss
ich ehrlich sagen das ist für mich
eigentlich die schönste belohnung und
ich die frauen im nächsten jahr wieder
sehen
mittlerweile ist es eine gewachsene
familie und die rosa kriegerin das ist
so eine kleine gruppe von was als kleine
gruppe deutschland bei verstreut auch
selbsthilfegruppe die tanzen wenn das
nächste mal da bist du siehst das wirst
es nicht glauben
die tanzen nie verrückt da ist eine
stimmung vor der bühne und die juden
mehr dazu und wenn ich dann sehe
sophie zu denen geht so gut das ist
eigentlich für mich das schönste
erlebnis
ja ich freue mich jetzt schon sehr auf
den abend
und natürlich auch vorher essen ich
glaube auf jeden fall hin ich halte dir
gerne mit jim und ich glaube wir konnten
den zuschauern ganz viele fragen
beantworten
die
hier seht ihr jetzt gerade wie ich mein
honig senf dressing aus meinem salat
grundrezept video zu breite für den
leckeren wildkräutersalat und da hinten
hat die liebe lisa des erz zubereitet
und die waren wirklich super lecker und
die liga hat auch einen eigenen blog da
heißt mein backen und da könnt ihr euch
auch gerne den link in der infobox
anschauen
jetzt seht ihr gerade wie wir die rekord
summe von 300.000 euro an die aktion
pink übergeben
und ich bin es wirklich sehr toll dass
es einfach unternehmen gibt die sich
ihrer sozialen verantwortung stellen und
das kitchenette wirklichen großes
vorbild ist und diese aktion auch macht
und ich denke der dank von mir und auch
von corinna und von der ganzen aktion
pink und von allen betroffenen geht auch
an euch denn ihr habt im prinzip
mitgeholfen und jeder der eine
kitchenette oder ein produkt von
kitchenaid in der farbe himbeereis
dieses jahr erworben hat hat zu dieser
spende beigetragen und ich denke da kann
man wirklich stolz drauf sein
die summe hat sich mehr als verdreifacht
im vergleich zu den letzten jahren
und falls es auch getroffen seit oder
betroffener kennt zum beispiel dann
könnt ihr euch gerne bei der aktion pink
meldeten die helfen euch auf jeden fall
die können euch sagen wo ihr hilfe
suchen könnt wo ihr
therapiemöglichkeiten habt oder
vielleicht habt ihr auch lust und zeit
und möchte gerne als ehrenamtliche bei
der aktion pink mithelfen das finde ich
auch ganz schön
vor allem gibt es diese rennen auch in
größeren städten an verschiedenen
stellen in deutschland und ich werde
bestimmt nicht auch an einer an einem
rennen mit mit dabei sein und mithelfen
das wird mir auch sehr viel freude
bereiten und alle anderen infos bekommt
ihr noch unten in der video beschreibung
und ja also vielen dank an alle und ich
fand sehr schön mit dabei zu sein auch
bei dem galadinner und fand eine sehr
schöne aktion also bis zum nächsten mal